[Music]
you have to find yourself and be happy
with what you have found before you can
give yourself to someone else that's
actually actually kind of relates to
something some things that I've been
going through so that's actually push
yourself to the limit you're almost
there
I agree I mean I hope it's true
yeah it's motivational I lived in a
different country have you know him do
you want to yeah we're the Netherlands
is pretty cool I want to travel abroad a
lot more traveling abroad is the best
and I also want to travel abroad more
and the last place I went to this Norway
Oslo specifically and I can't wait to go
back
have you ever been to the symphony
orchestra before why or why not
I've never been to the symphony
orchestra and I would like to go so I
don't have a reason why I haven't been
just that I haven't been able to get
there before but I will go in the future
would you like to travel to the east
coast well I've already traveled to the
east coast being New York and yeah it's
actually a pretty nice place but I would
travel there again should traffic cones
be a different color absolutely not I
think they should stay the same color
they're nice they're bright they catch
their eye catching they stop people my
opinion what in life is important to you
and
I would say family's important to me
because they're forever
I think the most important thing is
cuz they have be part
sometimes you'd give to the families if
you don't they're not positive or
there's no
I think the most important in life is
living every day to the fullest
life is choices make them count what are
your choices my choices would be making
the best out of even a negative
situation and always
knowing that there's gonna be better
days so basically staying positive was a
better day
stay positive there's always something
better
it's not a reason keep looking to the
stars
it's like always like look forward to
your project life of life like I don't
know if you want to be a artist you have
to do it and I like to prepare a prepare
every day in order to get that if I want
to be a super player I have to be
training every day and every day in
order to be the best
what are your story I'm trying to buy a
ship when I get all older so every day I
work harder and harder invest in some
projects in order to have a lot of money
and buy a ship and be deceive all the
time fishing and fishing and something
like that
we are you a hard-working guy from
Alaska flying around in San Diego
visiting family and friends as much as I
possibly can everywhere
what don't I do in Alaska is a better
question what was your happiest moment
recently
it was I think Friday Friday night
because I won't go out with my friends
in omnia club it was good if tomorrow is
your last day in this world what will
you want to do exactly what I'm doing
right now hanging out in the Sun with my
friends not worrying about anything
trying not to yeah this one day that's
it right so you have to take advantage
of it I think that I will be doing
exactly what I'm doing right now and
just again tomorrow yeah absolutely what
goal are you working toward right now if
you're not why not I just found out that
I'm gonna be a dad in May so we got to
get stuff ready so the goal is to oh boy
we got to get a house we got to get all
the baby stuff we got to get a lot of
stuff done but the goal is to be the
best dad possible by May
[Music]
thanks for watching another episode if
you haven't already it would mean a lot
if you subscribe to my channel like this
video share it a couple episodes of
friends and help support my project
thank you
[Music]